après l'intervention
après l'intervention de chagall lavrov
nous allons faire une petite pause et
après nous continuerons notre session
aux portes closes
sa représentants des médias allez-y
je vous remercie chers collègues chers
invités je suis heureux de vous
accueillir à moscou pour une nouvelle
réunion du format de moscou de
discussion
nous accordons une grande importance à
aux travaux de ce mécanisme puisque ça
correspond à la nécessité de trouver un
consensus régional et d'avoir une
compréhension sur les voies à suivre
pour régler la situation en afghanistan
est autour de lui et l'importance et la
priorité du format de moscou c'est que
cette plateforme comprend tous les
interlocuteurs qui peuvent avoir une
influence dans la région nous exprimons
nos regrets
quant à l'absence cette fois-ci de nos
collègues américains
et c'est la deuxième fois que les états
unis
refuse de participer à cette discussion
avec les représentants de chine de
pakistan et de la russie
j'espère que ce n'est pas lié à un
problème systémique
mais je suppose qu'une
dès
qu'une des raisons doit être le
changement de
nomination de la nomination d'un nouveau
responsable pour l'afghanistan aux états
unis et j'espère que sa part la
participation des états unis et que le
nouveau représentant participera aux
étapes suivantes de nos travaux et
notamment à la discussion de moscou dans
le respect je l'espère des accords qui
seront conclus
je rappelle que ce format de moscou
avait été mis en place en 2017 et en
novembre 2008 pour la première fois à
une même table des représentants du
mouvement des talibans et du
et du des autorités du pays s'étaient
rencontrés en la présence de
représentants de dix pays aujourd'hui il
est inutile de chercher
de chercher des responsables pour dans
l'échec de cette de ces discussions de
compromis aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est que le camp républicain
avec l'ancien président h afin de gagny
n'avait pas honoré les attentes
aujourd'hui il ya une nouvelle
administration qui est de pouvoir et ce
fait accompli fait qu'il ya donc une
responsabilité qui incombe maintenant
aux talibans aux talibans
donc il ya des efforts à faire en
matière de d'amélioration et de mise en
place des travaux du gouvernement et ce
développement durable
doit se faire est le gage de ce récit
c'est la mise en place d'un gouvernement
réellement inclusif qui puisse
représenter les intérêts non seulement
des forces ethniques mais des forces
politiques du pays et ainsi cette
perspicacité pourrait servir de leçon à
ceux qui veulent sacrifier les intérêts
nationaux
et abandonner le peuple
or on voit que l'évolution de la
situation aujourd'hui en afghanistan
on a un soutien massif de la population
de beaucoup de classe de la population
avec un respect des droits élémentaires
nous en avons parlé en détail avec la
délégation du mouvement des talibans
juste avant l'ouverture de cette
rencontre
donc le nouvel équilibre des forces qui
s'était établi après le 15 août dernier
fait qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui d'autre
moyens de discuter même si en même temps
au niveau interne internationale il n'y
a pas de reconnaissance officielle il ya
un certain nombre de problèmes sociaux
culturels
qui se posent et les nouvelles autorités
de kaboul sont confrontés à ces
problèmes ce tout cela montre qu' il est
difficile de qualifier de stab la
situation d'un pays mais on voit un
certain nombre de groupes terroristes
cherchent à utiliser cette situation et
notamment l'état islamique et al qaïda
qui de nouveau tente à relever la tête
et à faire des attaques sanglantes dans
différentes parties du pays
malheureusement on a toujours si le
problème du des narcotiques de la drogue
dans ce pays en afghanistan
qui se posent et cette activité autour
des narcotiques qui se masque derrière
des flux migratoires
en direction des pays voisins et dans ce
contexte ce qui nous préoccupe
essentiellement
en asie c'est
[Musique]
la stabilité en afghanistan et dans les
pays qui l'entourent et les problèmes
qui peuvent
déteindre sur d'autres pays aujourd'hui
nécessite une discussion avec l'ensemble
des partenaires et nous appelons le
mouvement des talibans et d'ailleurs
nous venons d'en parler avec cette
honorable
représentation c'est d'éviter d'utiliser
le territoire
de l'afghanistan au profit de pays tiers
et notamment de pays voisins et des pays
d'asie centrale qui sont nos élus en
même temps nous espérons
continuer à travailler notamment sous
l'égide de l'onu et de l'organisation de
shanghai et le tc aussi ainsi que
d'autres structures
multilatéral
le mois dernier à douchanbé il ya eu le
sommet de l'ôter sc
et de l'organisation de shanghai et il y
aussi une réunion spéciale
au sommet
consacré justement l'évolution de la
situation en afghanistan et ces réunions
ont montré que l'ensemble
de ces organisations sont tout à fait
préoccupés par la nécessité
l'hôtesse et a même un mécanisme spécial
qui avait été mise en place et les
pleurs années qu'il y ait justement
qui est dédiée à la coopération avec
l'afghanistan pour favoriser la
stabilisation de la situation dans le
pays nous sommes satisfaits des contacts
que nous avons avec les autorités
afghanes d'abord pour résoudre les
premières
missions qui consistent à aux biens des
de la population au fonctionnement de
notre ambassade à kaboul mais aussi des
ambassades d'autres pays
nous remercions
les talibans pour les possibilités
données à nos journalistes de travailler
afin de couvrir les allées les
événements
non
remercions aussi pour
d'avoir permis aux
compatriotes russes de rentrer dans leur
pays nous souhaitons que les étudiants
avaient afghans qui font leurs études en
russie puisse
continuer et que leur diplôme soit
reconnue nous allons poursuivre les
relations d'affaires avec
kaboul notamment sur les questions
bilatérales le développement de la
formation de l'instruction de la santé
publique des films des possibilités
financières tout cela nécessite la mise
en place de nouveaux organes de pouvoir
qui doivent s'accompagner d'efforts
particulièrement important
les messages sur la détérioration de
la situation de la population en
afghanistan sont inquiétants et pour une
grande part de la population afghane
aujourd'hui il ya une question
alimentaire qui se posent et nous
espérons que les représentants de la
délégation afghane ne feront pas
aujourd'hui de leurs
informations de premières sources sur la
situation et de notre côté nous sommes
convaincus que le temps est venu de se
mobiliser que l'ensemble de la commune i
communauté internationale se
mobilise sur le plan
politique sur le plan financier
et pour résoudre aussi la question des
flux migratoires et le sommet
exceptionnel du g20 sur l'afghanistan a
montré en tout cas la proximité de vue
des acteurs régionaux sur ces questions
et nous attendons une réponse
responsable
notamment de la part des pays
occidentaux qui
qui par leur présence au sur le pays ont
provoqué la situation actuelle et qui
n'ont pas
fait en sorte que l'afghanistan
se redresse sur le plan économique et
industriel il ya une aide pas seulement
humanitaire qui doit être apportée mais
aussi il ya la question des salaires du
personnel sur place les médecins les
enseignants etc nous sommes convaincus
que le rôle de consolidation
sur l'air de l'afghanistan est important
ici c'est une priorité et j'espère que
les appels collectif du format moscou
permettront aujourd'hui de proposer des
faire des propositions concrètes qui
seront entendues et que cela suscitera
des réactions positives les prochains
jours
nous allons envoyer au peuple afghan a
mis une aide humanitaire je vous
remercie pour votre attention et je vous
souhaite un travail tout à fait
fructueux
merci beaucoup monsieur lavrov